i think that was a sneaker honestly that
sparked me getting in the shoes in my
head as a ninth grader like yeah i'm
gonna get the concords and lose my
virginity the same week what's good gq
it's your boy corday and this is my life
and sneakers
[Music]
in maryland sneaker culture was was
everything you know in maryland this is
new balance and it's phone positives
it's nike boots i used to go to sneaker
cons and sneaker culture was very big
like we used to trade shoes even if it
was like temporary yeah i was i was on
23 years back and just always trying to
find a way to hustle to
get some sneakers some cousins of mine
stumbled upon a vault of sneakers that
may or may not have belonged to them
they showed me mad love by by because
there was all my size by breaking them
all off to me i was able to use these
sneakers as an asset
you know to sell them and
buy a studio with it and the rest is
history here we are today
all-time great the best memory i have
attached to a sneaker they're not here
it's two sneakers in particular the
concord is 2011 because that was the
first one i waited in line for i was in
ninth grade so i was a freshman i think
that was a sneaker honestly that sparked
me getting in the shoes in my head as a
ninth grader like yeah i'm gonna get the
concourse and lose my virginity the same
week the other shoe was the electric
blue phone posits with the pink shoe
laces and [ __ ] so i remember being a cfe
which is like this go-go spot i was in
eighth grade and i just remember like
trying to do whatever i could it
happened to snow like crazy too i
believe that weekend so i used to shovel
snow i used to walk to the neighborhoods
with the bigger houses to shovel they
snow to get more bread and just save and
stack and i had the bread to get the
electric blues wale is a real big
sneaker influence that [ __ ] be having
all the gear he's a real sneaker og you
know being from maryland as well so
that's the obvious one you know that's
what kanye got like his fresh [ __ ] from
he used to visit his cousins in tacoma
park and rarely used to call them bamas
and he's like now i gotta get on my fly
[ __ ] but i say that to say maryland dmv
area [ __ ] just refuse to be champ you
know what i'm saying like champ is like
a cardinal sin out there man for real
and we think we are the freshest [ __ ]
on earth like we always got to have our
gear up the par
okay so my enforcers i won't even call
these my beaters these is just my
go-to's every single day but these are
the beaters right here i brought these
specifically for that these
are my beaters these are like my
business casual go-to's you got what i'm
saying like if i got to go somewhere but
kind of be a little dressy or just on
some different fly [ __ ]
i'm gonna go with these i got probably
like a hundred pair of these
straight up not like 15 i'm slicing but
like a good 15 of just this same exact
colorway just in rotation and just
always make sure they're decently fresh
but still a little worn you know what
i'm saying like shout out to the good
folks at puma these are like i wear
these literally every [ __ ] day it's
not really a science we're performing my
goal like i said my go-to's for all
occasions is probably these joints but i
might like i said i'm performing those
louise as well i'll be performing in
these rick owens sometimes like these
are good just dog shoes you know these
dogs these drinks out but still on some
fly [ __ ] you know
these are like the freelance creative
starter kit sneakers you know what i'm
saying like if you're on some freelance
creative influencer [ __ ] then you're
going to have a pair of rick owens
mvp these are dnp 11s with the gold
dead stop still in the wrapper defining
moments pack
they got the gold jaunt right there as
well you know i always wanted these as a
kid and what i do now is i just get all
the sneakers that i always wanted as a
kid i got them i think when i was on
tour in like michigan or rand whenever i
be on tour i'd be going to like random
vintage shops these are 94 red ones this
is not the old ones these is not them
jones that y'all be having these are
older than me actually from cool kicks
la i went in there and i seen these i
was like
bro these 94 and it was like yeah they
are like you sure and i did my [ __ ] i'm
like
damn they are so i grabbed him instant i
only go looking for og's or or like the
first retros you know i think they were
like a thousand they actually they gave
them to me for free
superstar i guess the most expensive
ones i got on me today is these right
here the louis vuitton lv trainers and
these are also like i beat these joints
like did a lot of shows in these as well
but i love these sneakers because they
kind of remind me of one of my favorite
jordans of all time which is the
the cements right here i got a fresh
pair i got a dog pair these are my dog's
pair yeah so okay these are my most
expensive pair they five g's then yeah
you know i really got my bang for buck
man because it's like i said that i love
these so much because they remind me of
the black cement threes which is like
one of my favorite jordans of all time
and i know i dogged the [ __ ] out of
these as well but i kind of like my
shoes not to be dogged but to have
somewhere because it adds character you
know
can i just have like a just show y'all
some of my personal favorite moment okay
it's time for business business is
booming you know the 17s one of my
favorite jays underrated i think this is
the first jordans that went for like 200
the 17th i feel like are
underappreciated like everybody loved
the ones the fours the threes the 11s
the sevens and [ __ ] but i like a good
pair of seventeens man and i just love
the packaging you know like oh my god
it's so great like you know the
briefcase this is on some fly [ __ ] and
they like with the right type of jeans
they look really good like uncuffed with
these you know what i'm saying okay so
six man sneaker that i gotta wear
forever it's literally either to cement
black threes or them suede pumas it's
one of those two or them rick owens but
the rigs don't go with everything like
so yeah either one of these two or i'm
gonna just bring these one of these
three
[Music]
that's what i have right now i recently
moved and i gave away a lot of shoes
honestly because i had like 300 pair of
shoes i want to say maybe like 200 and i
was like man i probably wear 50 of these
if that so i just gave away like 150
pair of shoes
[Music]
because i don't really wear these ones
like that
i can wear any outfit and throw on
whatever and put both of these sneakers
on and i'm damn near good if i had to
eliminate one i don't know
i don't know man i really can't true
this is just crazy i'm an overthinker so
this is just too much for me my final my
my final reasoning wasn't from a pure
place it was like damn i'm not sponsored
by jordan because like you can't even
tell they're louis vuitton unless you
like really look you know they don't
scream at you i'm just thinking on some
just grown man but you still young
[ __ ] swag that's these all day
so y'all heard me talk about my sneakers
appreciate gq for having me i'll see
y'all next time oh yeah y'all know i'm
on the gq cover too with y'all so me and
jq you know we go we go way back we like
this